like guys like you mess it up every time
maybe you just need a partner
dr. PIM I actually heard what happened
to you it's crazy could be closed stole
your tech deal and Jessica
this video
ant-man the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
she seems more intense
[Applause]
hey everybody it's Charlie's we got new
amen and the wasp footage to break down
and a lot of you have been asking about
the time-travel theories that have been
flying around involving the quantum
realm and some of ant-man and the wasps
abilities in Avengers 4 given that they
don't have the Infinity Gauntlet and
they don't have dr. strange who even
though he used to have the time gem also
had the ability to create portals all
over the multiverse so convenient fast
travel that they lost access to so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a black panther blu-ray giveaway
that's going on and they just announced
when they're dropping the infinity war
blu-ray - so I'll do a giveaway for that
as soon as they start selling it but
obviously as we talk about this because
we're gonna be talking about infinity
war spoilers for infinity Wars so just
careful if you have not seen that movie
yet but it has since been confirmed that
Ant Man of the wasp picks up before the
events of infinity war which is why
they're not talking about what's going
on with Thanos they're not talking about
New York or any other Wakanda battle or
any of the ashes per Scott Lang he's
still under house arrest you see the FBI
agents you see that ankle bracelet we
actually learned about a couple of the
new minor characters like Randall Parks
character turns out he's an FBI agent so
it looks like they have a little bit of
connective tissue like spider-man
homecoming hat at the beginning of that
film just to let you know where you were
in the timeline like okay I've been
arrested I was on the lam because
Captain America freed me from the rat so
my family couldn't handle it I cut a
deal now I'm under house arrest
but in all these trailers they've had a
conversation with his daughter where
she's like you know what you just need a
partner it sounds like he actually does
try to help people while he's under
house arrest and it just goes badly you
find out about what's going on with the
ghosts then that creates the need for
them to team up as a man of the wasp
because ant-man by himself would get his
ass handed to him by ghost like you see
him getting kicked through the wall
during the trailer that could be
happening at any point during the movie
but it sounds like he tries to take her
on by himself before he teams up with
the wasp and Hank Pym we also learned a
little bit about Walton Goggins Sonny
birch character he is somebody from the
comics but in the movie they're using
him as mostly what you would call a
small-time thief so he's not the main
villain that's gonna be the ghost he's
going to have some association with the
quantum realm and I think I talked a lot
about the Goliath character in my last
big trailer so Laurence Fishburne is
playing Goliath from the cob
if you didn't know he'll also help them
in their mission to save Janet Van Dyne
from the quantum realm and take down the
ghost
just because he's a former protege of
hank pym so they're just gonna be
dealing with the people in their
universe I wouldn't be surprised if
there was a little bit of crossover with
other minor characters I'm not expecting
Hawkeye to pop up but you can kind of
see how they're basically doing a lot of
the characters that did not appear
during infinity war so the only real
infinity war stuff that I'm expecting
you to see during the movie is either
gonna be the post-credits scene because
of the finger snap they have to address
that because of the timeline then
potential Avengers for I think it's a
little more meaningful if one of them
turns to ash and they don't over explain
it they leave that for Avengers 4 but I
think the idea is they want to use this
movie as a palate cleanser after the
really downer ending that infinity war
had so whatever their post-credits scene
that teases finger-snap and Avengers for
plot I think there'll be some funny way
that they undercut that while at the
same time letting you know oh [ __ ] all
this stuff just happened they'd be kind
of quiet about it but there was a little
bit of footage in the last trailer in
more clear stuff recently where we saw
Janet Van Dyne in her classic wasp
costume so it looks like we will see
flashbacks in the film that will show
you her doing really badass stuff just
remember that her costume is all red
just like ant-man's classic costume the
costume that he wore in the first film
is the old one that hank pym used to
wear the one that he's wearing right now
the helmet is new as of Civil War and
the coloring is just a little bit
different but it's mostly meant to hype
up the new wasp costume because that is
brand-new is a redesigned version of the
prototype that we saw in the original
ant-man movies post credit scene but
time-travel in the quantum realm so
here's the really cool thing about the
quantum realm is that it replaces some
of the abilities that we lost when we
lost Doctor Strange in the time gem that
regulator is compromised you would go
subatomic
what does that mean it means that you
would enter a quantum realm what does
that mean it means that you would enter
a reality we're all concepts of time and
space become irrelevant as you shrink
the quantum realm is a different
dimension time moves differently in
space also it's a little bit different
so the cool thing is is that you enter
the quantum realm you can
accident it anywhere in the universe
which means that you can use it for a
quick travel the reason why I think they
have that special spaceship to travel
around inside the quantum realm is to
make it much easier because during the
original ant-man movie when he went down
in there he kind of got lost
he didn't have much of a propulsion
system so it sounds like this ship is
just meant to protect them from anything
that's alive down there because there
are living beings they call it the
Microverse but technically there's some
copyright issues with the Micronauts
which is a different franchise that's
controlled by a different company so
that's why they have to call it the
quantum realm but normally it would be
called the Microverse meaning that
there's races of beings that live in
there into the course of going down in
there to get Janet Van Dyne out they'll
also probably learn some things that
they can use it for like hey you know
this is a very dangerous place but we
can actually use it to enter anywhere we
want and exit anywhere we want in space
the time-travel aspect is just a
function of time moving differently in
there so a lot of people now are like
maybe the Avengers could use that to
move around in time space to take things
back or undo some of what Thanos did
without actually having the Infinity
Gauntlet itself part of fixing
everything is gonna require them getting
the gems from Thanos and either forging
a new gauntlet or putting the gems in
Iron Man's armor which I think it'd
probably be more likely scenario because
if people are badass and Marvel could
sell another Iron Man toy which makes
them more money which just sounds like a
very Disney thing to do the other
time-travels stuff people have been
talking about are these
behind-the-scenes pictures of them in
their original Avengers costumes the
Russos confirmed that this is them be ar
effing past events so they're using
their memories to remember what happened
during the original Avengers movie
they're not actually physically
traveling back in time in this moment
here that doesn't mean that there won't
be any time travel in the movie it just
means that this particular scene is not
time travel a lot of you were also
asking me about Sebastian Stan's
comments about Janet Van Dyne Hank Pym
in like all of the MCU actors standing
together on screen for a scene during
Avengers 4 so I think that there'll be
some moment because they're closing down
the first 10 years of Marvel movies and
moving into more crazy space based
franchises like the Eternals and doing
more black panther they want to have
some sort of celebratory moment where
they acknowledge all their achievements
and say look at how far we've come now
let's go on to the next thing so as part
of that big honorary moment it sounds
like they'll find a way to work all
those characters on screen like you
would see during this Marvel 10-year
anniversary photo a very brief version
of that during the movie hopefully it
won't be during a funeral for Captain
America or someone that would actually
be one logical reason for them to all be
on-screen together if they were honoring
the fallen during some memorial service
but remember the whole point of the
ant-man character is that he's really
good at stealing stuff and he's kind of
a hero so let me know how you think
they're gonna use that character in the
quantum realm to steal the gems from
Thanos during Avengers 4 what'll happen
next is is I'll post my Deadpool Easter
eggs Sunday morning be sure to go see
the movie if you haven't yet
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner two lone wolf
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
what are you wait for everything click
here for my Deadpool to post credits
scene video and click here for my brand
new infinity war video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
you